the Prime Minister on a Christmas visit
to a soup kitchen in the middle of a
cost of living crisis eager to show that
he has the common touch
but Rishi sunak's relationship with
money is far from common
the long-awaited release of his tax
returns show that this prime minister is
one of the super rich
this summary document shows the PM made
nearly 5 million pounds in the last
three years just over one million pounds
of this with income including 329 000
pounds last year from his salary as pm
and from shares the rest nearly 4
million pounds was the capital gains
generated on a us-based blind Trust
paying just over 1 million pounds in tax
on 4.8 million pounds of income means
his effective tax rate is just 22
capital gains more likely tax than a
salary
far away from a dramatic day in
Westminster the prime minister in Wales
purely a coincidence that his tax return
finally emerged with so many
distractions in Parliament well I
published my tax returns because I said
I would in the interest of transparency
and I'm glad to have done that now I
think what ultimately what people are
interested in is what I'm going to do
for them experts say this document gives
us a glimpse of significant wealth it's
clearly a vast sum of money we don't
know exactly how much it is but it's
into the millions and it could be
anything from 5 to 15 to 20 million
pounds of wealth and that's a big number
from compared to what we've seen in past
prime ministers this confirms Rishi
sulac is independently wealthy but we
already knew that what we didn't know is
that so much of his wealth is bound up
in the United States rather than the
United Kingdom and the bulk of it comes
from an American Investment known as a
blind trust now Rishi sunak knows what
went into that trust when it was created
but we've got no right to know and what
generates his cash
for most Prime Ministers payday comes
after high office for this one it came
before Sam coat Sky News Westminster